[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 8
février
les travaux se poursuivent à la mairie
de maurepas entamé il ya plusieurs mois
ceux ci permettront un meilleur accueil
du public dans un nouvel espace
modernisés d'ici le printemps prochain
la colle et les ballons de handball
plutôt que les pistards et les vélos le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueillera
bientôt un match de d1 féminine de
handball jusqu'à 5000 spectateurs sont
attendus pour l'occasion c'est
obligatoire au moins une fois par an le
ramonage de sa cheminée permet d'éviter
des accidents et d'assurer sa sécurité
nous avons suivi une entreprise de
montigny le bretonneux spécialisée dans
le domaine alors que les interventions
se multiplient en ce moment je vous le
disais en titre les travaux de la mairie
de mort pas se poursuivre débuté en
octobre dernier il vise à rénover
l'accueil des habitants et les
conditions de travail à des agents un
chantier nécessaire le bâtiment n'a pas
été réhabilité depuis 25 ans au
printemps prochain les morts patiens
découvriront donc un espace complètement
revu et modernisé elle le reportage de
camille lambert alors l'anguille voici
le rez de chaussée de la mairie de
maurepas aujourd'hui et voici à quoi il
ressemblera en juin prochain
un espace lumineux et optimisé pour
guider les visiteurs dans leurs
démarches
cette rénovation qui doit faire passer
le bâtiment à l'ère numérique répond à
plusieurs objectifs
le premier c'est d'améliorer l'accueil
des usagers donc desmaures pas bien
voire même des personnes qui n'habitent
pas encore mort pas c est également
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
des agents de la collectivité
les travaux coûtent 900000 euros ils
sont financés par la mairie qui recevra
une subvention de 180000 euros du
département
la future organisation comprendra un
guichet unique et deux autres niveaux
d'accueil où seront répartis les
visiteurs afin d'éviter les
encombrements faire des travaux au sein
même du rez de chaussée va permettre
d'avoir trois types d'accueil différents
accueil où on pourra directement informé
les morlaisiens sur l'actualité de la
vie vous avez après un deuxième accueil
où il ya plus de confidentialité pour
traiter un certain nombre de sujets
notamment sur l'état civil et vous avez
un troisième niveau d'accueil là il ya
un niveau de confidentialité plus
important ce bâtiment érigé dans les
années 70 avait conservé la même
structure depuis plus de 25 ans c'est
dire s'il était temps de lui donner un
nouveau souffle
il est prévu comme je le dis dans le
cadre des travaux une isolation pour
permettre aussi aux agents de travailler
dans de meilleures conditions parce que
avant il y avait des courants d'air on
avait même des plus dans les moquettes
on à du mobilier qui avaient l'âge de la
précédente rénovation d'hôtels de ville
cette rénovation s'inscrit dans une
modernisation plus large des services
publics un site internet baptisé espace
citoyen est ouvert depuis septembre
dernier on peut y réaliser certaines
démarches sans avoir à passer par la
mairie
les résultats sont tombés et sont
désormais officiel la cgt reste la
première force syndicale au sein des
très petites entreprises un résultat qui
fait suite aux élections organisées
début janvier elle la cgt rassemble sur
sa liste un peu plus de 25% des
suffrages dans une élection est
largement boudé avec un taux
d'abstention qui dépasse les 92% en île
de france par exemple seulement 53 mille
personnes ont voté sur une base
électorale d'un million de concernés
écoutez à ce propos la secrétaire
générale départementale de la cgt sonia
porot nous l'avons interrogé sur le
sujet hier lors d'une manifestation à
versailles
la cgt a mené un grand travail de
proximité en diffusant des tracts sur
les lieux de travail avec des réunions
d'information selon les métiers
mais c'est vrai que l'abstention est due
aussi au report des élections et ça
c'est la décision du ministère du
travail
la combativité de la cgt contre la loi
travail mais aussi son travail au
quotidien dans les unions locales et
dans les entreprises est reconnu par par
les salariés donc on va continuer
évidemment ce ce travail et la cgt plus
de dix points devant la cfdt donc c'est
vraiment un écart significatif et sachez
enfin pour conclure sur cette
information qu aller chez leur région
al comme à l'échelle nationale la cfdt
se place en deuxième position dans cette
élection avec 15 5% des voix exprimées
du sport à présent et le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
qui va troquer les vélos pour les
ballons de handball ici paris clubs de
d1 va délocaliser pour la première fois
de son histoire un match à domicile dans
l'enceinte yvelinoise pour affronter le
club de brest
objectif battre les bretons mais aussi
le record d'affluence pour un match de
première division qui est de 5000
spectateurs
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
et mathilde de 2 me ce sera une grande
première au vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un match de d1
féminine de handball va être organisée
le samedi 25 mars dans la structure avec
au programme une rencontre de haut
niveau entre les clubs d'ici paris et de
brest là on est ravis d'accueillir deux
ans dont on espère après pour acteurs du
basket du volley et voilà c'est l'idée
c'est vraiment d'inscrire cette salle
qui est une salle de 6500 personnes on
m'accepte sur notre capacité maximale en
fait de pouvoir l'optimiser et de
l'utiliser comme une
une vraie salle de sports et spectacles
j'ai encore un peu de mal à me projeter
parce que c'est un peu grand et c'est un
peu lointains par rapport aux places en
hausse des spectateurs donc se passer
excitant et en même temps ça fait un peu
peur la rencontre sera avant tout un
choc du championnat entre les deux co
leaders de la division des stars du
handball féminin seront sur la feuille
de match parmi les joueuses on
retrouvera la demi centre steen oft
dalle médaillé de bronze aux derniers jo
avec la norvège est championne du monde
ça va être très très quoi un match très
important pour nous moi j'ai bien joué
des matches comme ça aussi avec
l'impression avec monk augmente c'est ça
qu'on connaît du monde
il devrait y en avoir l'objectif annoncé
ce mardi 7 février en conférence de
presse et de battre le record de 5100 27
places vendues pour un match de d1
féminine
pour atteindre ce chiffre les premiers
tickets sont accessibles à 5 euros
bah déjà j'espère que le record sera
atteint en tant que joueuse bas c'est
une énorme c'est un énorme événement
donc
a dit être et en même temps on a un peu
d'appréhension parce qu'on sait qu'on
sera vu par beaucoup de personnes et on
sait qu'il faudra justement faire une
belle prestation
en attendant ce match de gala les
joueuses d'ici paris se sont déjà
familiarisés avec l'enceinte sportive en
s'essayant aux traditionnels baptêmes de
piste le handball et le vélodrome une
histoire qui roule déjà sport toujours
mais dans un autre registre avec le
vendée globe vous avez suivi son périple
chaque semaine ou presque sur tv fil 78
pour sa deuxième participation le rambo
litas louis burton a réussi à boucler
son tour du monde en solitaire et sans
escale le jeudi 2 février en 87 jours
seulement avec son imoca à bureau vallée
il a largement battu ses objectifs
initiaux en terminant septième de la
course
retour sur son périple avec notre
journaliste michael et demi d'euros
louis burton 31 ans originaire de
rambouillet s'est élancé pour le vendée
globe le 6 novembre dernier
le marin pris le départ de cette
compétition de plus les sables d'olonne
aborde son imoca bureau vallée en
compagnie de 28 autres skippers ça fait
trois jours qu'on est parti tout pile et
on avait pris un bon départ on était
bien positionné là pour la première nuit
à la table du cap finistère
et puis
petit souci technique sans gravité mais
qui ont pris pas mal de temps nous faut
faire une deuxième nuit pas top
après un mois de course ses proches lui
manque dans ce tour du monde en
solitaire et sans escale le navigateur
comme unique a vécu en l'envoyant des
dizaines de mails par jour et des vidéos
on voit bien le bateau va vite moi je
suis en pleine forme
vous me manquez beaucoup beaucoup je
n'arrête pas de regarder des photos et
je vais mettre une petite chanson
toujours droit début décembre le skipper
est ancré à la 11e place mais le
navigateur ne fait pas la course seul
des baleines sont venus lui tenir
compagnie pendant son périple au large
de l'australie
une baleine une banane sur quoi
aussi proche
après 87 jours de course oui burton est
de retour au port des sables d'olonne
au classement le navigateur termine
finalement septième de cette huitième
édition
pas vraiment mon temps d'éclairage je
m'attendais on m'avait dit que ça serait
très fort et surtout c'est de voir
autant de monde autant de monde d'un
coup au bout de trois mois de solitude
c'est un vrai vrai vrai bonheur en fait
le marin devrait participer à une
troisième édition du vendée globe avec
un bateau équipé des dernières
technologies
de quoi cette fois-ci rivaliser que les
premiers du classement c'est une
obligation mais aussi une question de
sécurité le ramonage des cheminées
permet d'éviter chaque année à des
accidents le nombre d'interventions
augmentant plein hiver nous avons pu
suivre l'une d'entre elles chez un
particulier à montigny le bretonneux
reportage d'alice deschamps et mathilde
demi bonheur quelques milliers de
cheminées sont ramenés par an pour la
sécurité des yvelinois abois absurdes ou
à gaz
le ramonage est une obligation une fois
par an pour les assurances en cada 110
ont dit deux fois par an c'est pour les
gens qui brûlent énormément et consorts
des quantités genre style un stack
poubelles ou de sacs poubelles de suisse
là on force les gens à faire un deuxième
pour leur propre sécurité
ce qu'on joue pas avec le feu comme en
france on enregistre un incendie
domestique toutes les deux minutes
parmi ces incendies les feux de cheminée
sont une cause récurrente que
j'entretiens tous les ans je vois pas la
différence en fait c'est juste si je le
faisais pas tous les deux ans ou trois
ans éventuellement là je constaterai une
différence mais là je le fais une fois
par an donc il y a
je vois aucune différence quand je fais
une influence feu de cheminée
si les terres à manille ou pas je vais
ouvrir une fenêtre pour faire un appel
d'air comme ça quand je ramène trois
morts la suisse à la ramène dans la
cheminée pour éviter la suite qui
s'accumulent dans les conduits les
ramoneurs ou quelques techniques et
conseils pour éviter une cheminée
boucher aura bonne jusqu'à que ben y'a
plus rien qui tombent du conduit ou à
part quand c'est du bistre du lycée de
la suite s'agglomèrent le fait de brûler
des bêtises les cas j'ai des cartons
dans les trucs comme ça où des bois
traité et ça provoque du bist ça fait
des morceaux comme du charbon de bois et
c'est ça qui provoquent des incendies
un bon entretien des conduits de
cheminées de gaz ou de fioul sont
nécessaires et doivent être ramenées
pour éviter les incendies
on referme ce journal avec du cinéma on
ce mercredi du cinéma pour les tout
petits à magny les hameaux
la ville organise plusieurs fois par an
des séances ciné câlin à l'estaminet à
partir de 2 ans pour une première
approche du septième art à la fiche il
ya quelques jours devant une vingtaine
d'enfants et de parents un film
d'animation pour découvrir les berceuses
du monde entier et à franc succès chez
les petits comme chez les plus grands
écoutez j'ai adoré les berceuses
africaine parce que là on est quasiment
en train de danser
1 et puis anglaise aussi l'été y avait
beaucoup d'humour
ça reflète vraiment les cultures des
différents pays et des ambiances
voilà c'était c'était vraiment chouette
c'est sale avantages des spectacles pour
les tout petits c'est que en tout petit
vient forcément avec ses parents ses
grands-parents et du coup ça ouvre aussi
les portes des spectacles aux ans aux
adultes qui ont oublié qu'ils pouvaient
aussi entrées dans les salles de
spectacle
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal rendez
vous demain jeudi aux horaires habituels
pour une nouvelle édition locale d'ici
là tous nos reportages sont à retrouver
sur notre site internet et tv fil 78
points com ou sur l'application tv fil
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]